Everyone knows that we are social
identities and ideological identities,
their religious or cultural,
intellectual,
whatever.
Nobody's really paid much attention to
studying how the representations of that
cultural identity,
um,
alter the manner in which we feel
emotion,
which English is perceived by which we
act.
I'm interested in how our internal
representations of our culture modulator
or emotional expression,
that's the best way to say no.
Your brain basically,
it's programmed as your social lives.
That's what socialization is for.
Obviously it's socialization that
instills cultural identity and equally
obviously the process of socialization
that leads to cultural identity has to
have some impact on the way you think.
Obviously lay that on the way that your
mind functions and the way that your
brain functions and see North American
neuropsychologists have been loath to
give any consideration to this sort of
notion to think that cultural
transformations might have some direct
impact on physiological function by the
time the Russians.
By contrast,
this has been a central tenant of their
nurse neuro psychological theories.
Basically since,
since day one.
This is particularly true with regards
to Alexander learning and the God.
See,
now you can think about this.
It's quite obvious if you think about it
for a second,
with regards to something like the
capacity to read silently.
Now here's the case that what?
This is a relatively new talent.
Literacy is a new talent,
right?
Most people aren't able to read 500
years ago.
It's only been 500 years and only for a
little bit of that,
that the capacity to read has been
widespread and the capacity to read
silently as a relatively new development
in human history.
Now it's a good thing if you think about
it,
but nonetheless the capacity to read
silently localized to a specific part of
the brain,
which is to say it's as if you have a
part of the brain that's evolved for
that purpose.
It's the same place and everybody more
or less their individual variations or
differences when people are allowed to
realize differently,
but all that aside,
if you learn to read,
there was a party of this specializes
for that and it's pretty much the same
place and everyone and it wasn't there
or wasn't doing that sort of Bot
activity.
Two thousand years ago,
in fact,
I read at one point,
I don't know where the reference to this
is like so many things that I make
reference to,
but I've had at one point that people
thought Julius Caesar was a magician in
part and he was obviously a remarkable
person,
but in part because he can read
silently,
he didn't have to read aloud,
so it wasn't just reading.
It was remarkable.
It was being able to read without
talking.
Anyways,
the point of all this is that your
brain,
this is learning.
His view of the brain fundamentally is
your brain is an organ that produces sub
organs,
culturally specific subordinates,
not since that's it's remarkable
capacity is that it can generate new
molecules that are specialized for
certain tasks.
As a consequence of environmental
program.
This is an interesting notion which is
to say that at some level of
physiological analysis,
at least your culture determines how you
bring worse.
Now,
it's very plastic.
Your brain is very plastic.
When were a child,
you can sustain immense amounts of
critical damage.
In childhood.
I still grow up normally.
For example,
if you're a very,
very epileptic as a child,
sometimes what surgeons will do is take
out a whole hemisphere,
the right hemisphere on and children who
have hysterectomy is if they're done
young enough,
still brought to be relatively normal,
quite normal.
In fact,
in the other cases too,
where people are hydrocephalic,
which basically means that they're
ventricles don't vamped properly,
um,
and cerebral spinal fluid builds up in
the scouts.
These people often have stalls that are
slightly larger than normal,
not necessarily obvious,
but what steel case.
And they ended up with a skull.
It's essentially full of liquid with a
very,
very thin layer of brain tissue around
this is all liquid and there are a
number of case reports of people who
have like five percent of the fishing
tact who have high functioning
intelligence.
His normal personality,
so point is your,
especially the higher cortical levels of
your brain are very,
very functionally flexible.
We can childhood now by the time you
have adult,
you know,
the pattern changes a little bit.
Guy Of looks like your brain dies into
it's adult configuration.
That's an interesting at which is to say
you have way more neurons need,
especially right before you're born and
environment,
prunes your brain down to its adult
configuration,
so of course you develop connections as
well,
but if you lose a lot of neurons,
so by the time you're an adult you're
brain is nowhere near as flexible as it
was when you were a child and if you
have sustained damage to certain parts
of you that are already specialized
while you hold any,
have the damage and you can work around
it,
but it can still be really prominent
question.
So that's sort of the market and it's.
Yeah,
that's right because the brain adapts or
as the body.
That's a great comment.
You know,
and if you start thinking about that,
it has really revolutionary implication.
So you can say,
for example,
if I have an idea that's really radical
in the sense that changes the
configuration of my core tasks,
I can transmit that maybe not to you.
Maybe your brain is already fixed,
so to speak.
Put down the generations and altered the
structure of brains,
hand sports.
So you could say,
well,
ideas can spread through a population
that way.
That's a lamarckian spread.
Even more interesting,
I think this is speculative of course,
but let's say that there are certain
types of revolutions in thought that are
actually the consequences of biological
mutations.
So you could sing that well,
you're a particularly odd sort of person
from the genetic perspective and as a
consequence you think,
and a very,
very unique matter.
But the thing that's so interesting is
that if you can still communicate those
thoughts,
then the effect of that genetic mutation
be transmitted throughout the population
without any biological alteration at the
genetic level at all.
So that's really something,
something that's interesting because it
means that the consequences of genetic
mutation.
So in competition can spread throughout
the population is fast as communication
could move.
So that's,
yeah,
the Lamarckian everybody know what the
transmission is.
Well,
Lamarck was the character who thought
that the reason that that you could,
you can transmit acquired
characteristics.
So the reason drafts at Lomax is because
it kept trying to stretch their next
basically.
So,
and they transmitted the capacity to do
stretching to their offspring so you can
transmit acquired characteristics down
the genetic line,
but there's no,
you can't do that.
That's wrong.
But that's what Lamar thought.
But he wasn't completely wrong because
there is.
That is how this sort of transmission
works.
It's non genetically mediated cumulation
of biological resources.
So that's very interesting.